había temor sin duda y muchísima gente
como lo dijo y lo confirmó el alcalde
había salido de la ciudad sin embargo
fue un día extremadamente tranquilo ya
básicamente se ha terminado este 24 de
febrero Este primer aniversario muy
diferente a lo que vivieron exactamente
hace un año cuando las cinco de la
mañana empezaron esas explosiones Y esa
invasión a gran escala con el temor que
tenían entonces de que el presidente
Vladimir Putin pensaba que en tres días
ya iba a tener el control de esta ciudad
sin embargo actitudes como la del
presidente boludo mirzalensky que
decidió quedarse y dijo que aquí estaría
con el resto de los ucranianos y les dio
armas para que pudieran también unirse
miles de personas y miles que no tenían
ningún pasado militar pero querían
defender el país pues esto hizo un gran
cambio en el país y esto también lo
recordó hoy que cuando hizo una rueda de
prensa con los periodistas muchos de los
periodistas acreditados para esta
primera aniversario de esta invasión a
gran escala hablo de China no fue tan
fuerte como lo ha sido como la Unión
Europea trató de crear puentes con ellos
habló sobre latinoamérica dijo que
estaba dispuesto a ir a hablar con
dirigentes de latinoamérica para
explicarle la situación de Ucrania y
ganar su apoyo y lo mismo hizo con
África también habló de Israel de ese
apoyo que ellos básicamente esa cercanía
que tiene a Rusia y dijo que eso se
refería también a una historia pasada
histórica de Rusia Así que fue una
conferencia de prensa también
sentimental pero en la cual dijo que la
victoria llegaría si sus aliados
europeos siguen apoyando